come and join the carnival huh electric
daisy carnival in town this weekend lots
of colorful characters making their way
here to our city got team coverage here
at this noon hour eight news now
reporter mary jane belliesa joining us
at the airport as festival goers arrive
there but first send things over to nate
tannenbaum he's got a look at the
weekend weather and boy it's windy out
there nate it is it won't be quite as
windy over the weekend the temperatures
for the first couple of days actually
should be great we're talking about
temps about 20 degrees cooler and
heather i don't want to say i'm old but
i remember when it was the steam-powered
daisy carnival
all right here are your numbers at noon
at read international check this out
we're hanging at 75 that is exactly 20
degrees cooler than this time 24 hours
ago winds over 15 gusting to 30 miles an
hour you see the palm tree whipping
around out there the clark county
department of environment and
sustainability's division of air quality
has issued a dust alert if you have
breathing issues this is a good day to
stay indoors the only weather alerts
from the national weather service those
red flag warnings for high heat low
humidity and strong winds only for lake
mead and also into northwestern arizona
triple digits are in the eight day
forecast in a few minutes heather